I actually deliver something I was
really weird I kind of like looked at
the label of come on man everybody's
curious and it was a freaking a rabbit
do you know what a rabbit is it was a
dildo dogs are very aggressive towards
delivery people I've had some people say
yes no it depends on the person but I
thought it was a myth until I went into
this yard you always have to make sure
you do a pre-check a free dog check I've
never had a bad experience with a dog
every time I went into a house or an
apartment complex it was like you know
you tap on the gate and you go give it
about three seconds dogs pick up on your
fear so of course if you're scared then
they're gonna pick up on that I remember
one time it was a big-ass cane corso
like a big black beast of a dog I did my
pre check and then the front door was
open I was like no that's I didn't have
a dog son so I went in there deliver the
package and then I heard a whole bunch
of growling I turned around and had a
head like this big
I just meant not just I bolted but if
you're nice and you're just a generally
good person you should be fine I feel
like people try to deliver illegal
things coffee a lot of times you will be
driving and random people strategies
just run up and chase the truck hey or
like trying to run after you to try to
give a package to you you could tell
that it's kind of off because the guy
seemed kind of sketchy like you know he
wouldn't have any identification or
anything you just try to hand you a
package with like this fake air waybill
owner you don't know what's in it at all
people try to deliver all kinds of
things weird stuff you know like blow
ups and stuff like that my point oh I've
delivered a box the contents of it was
like really light weight kind of funny
it was like rolling around the box it
just smelled awful it probably was
somebody's head to be honest fuzz sports
manure cow manure you can smell it it's
just so strong you can
it was just funny you can actually say
no to a delivery of course don't want to
do it sometimes I get in trouble for it
I doubt if I will get in trouble for
saying no I mean I don't really care a
lot of times when you're dealing with
foreign objects and that goes back to
the legal issue or sometimes it's really
heavy or just like an odd shape you
can't say no just because of a gut
feeling the hardest part about delivery
times is everything traffic always like
parking again now scanning it is the
most stressful part about the job trying
to hit delivery times because it could
be 300 stops and into deliveries at each
stop it can be very stressful especially
when you have a business account and
expect to have their delivery between a
certain time if I can remember you have
to be off the truck within less than a
minute you have to think 10 stops ahead
you have to park the car put the hazard
zone close the window close the side
mirror go to the back grab the package
and by that time it has to be less than
a minute like and you have to be already
going like it it should take you on
average about a minute and 30 seconds
for the Libero bag things get delayed it
can be whether to be transit it's a lot
of different things that comes into
account there are even stories of a guy
that I knew when he was driving he
actually called in that the hub in the
dispatches and said come get the truck
I'm done literally said come get the
truck I'm done they left the truck on
the side of the road with a whole bunch
of packages in it it is that kind of job
it is like a it's only the strong I
definitely have repressed a lot of
memories while I was working at UPS
usually forget all of my really terrible
days worst day on that job was when you
get there in the morning and your whole
entire truck was in disarray not having
every package I need to have for
delivery things not being an order the
loaders are the most important people to
UPS drivers because if the loader
doesn't do their jobs and guess what
you're out on the road you're missing
boxes and you don't know where the boxes
when picking up packages all over the
floor I think boxes falling traffic
maybe you get there to the location
there's nobody answered the door it's
being cluttered [ __ ]
it's just one of those jobs where
everything falls apart if everything is
not exactly in place you just have to
plan for the worst
for me it was not the best job in the
world I honestly don't recall the best
day I've ever had at work it has yet to
happen I have never had a best day maybe
getting done before the Sun Goes Down
because once the Sun Goes Down you can't
see the addresses you can't see where
you're going of traffic gets heavier my
best stay on a job with me all the
packages aren't where they supposed to
be there are a number they're all
ordered nothing's missing not having
like any traffic or parking issues get
mostly residential and not so much as
business simply because the residential
ZAR easier to hit you can get out the
car and just run drop it off run drop it
off not getting any type of feedback
from a client or customer well you get a
customer that actually cares and they
give you a bottle of water that's about
it I don't think a great day if there's
one thing that I can say people could do
better is just just do your best to put
down all the correct information on the
bills if you have a label on the package
has to be scanned and then the driver we
can't really scan like packages that
have been entered to the system yet
things just get misplaced and things
like don't turn out the way you want it
you're just one person like we have so
many people to hit and the only thing
you to care about is getting your mail
so just be mindful that you know bad
things happen along the way put it where
it's supposed to go if you want it to be
picked up and put it we're supposed to
go little to like to drop off places
they're there for a reason so many times
where I deliver something and the person
can't sign for it because they're not
the person on the package and then they
get mad and I get mad a lot of people's
information is not lining up to you know
to the expectation of the delivery the
advice I would give you about your mail
is just be happy to get it yes
[Music]